but first our top story this half-hour
Israel and the West Bank are on edge
this morning as the region braces for
historic change clashes turned deadly
Friday between Israeli forces and
Palestinians at the Gaza border and
tensions are likely to increase ahead of
Monday's controversial relocation of the
US Embassy from Tel Aviv to Jerusalem
Jerusalem is of a particular concern as
Israelis and Palestinians both claim it
as their capital Holly Williams has more
from Gaza this morning Holly good
morning good morning here in Gaza
yesterday thousands of Palestinians
protested along that fence about a
hundred and fifty yards behind me that
separates the tiny Gaza Strip where they
live from Israel we saw Palestinian
demonstrators burning tires hurling
rocks and trying to pull down sections
of Defense Israeli soldiers on the other
side fired tear gas canisters and
bullets they've been holding these
protests now for around six weeks and
more than 40 Palestinians have been
killed including one yesterday hundreds
more have been injured the fence cuts
off the Palestinians who live here in
the Gaza Strip from the outside world
because of a more than ten year long
blockade that has made this
poverty-stricken place even more
desperate the Palestinian protesters are
demanding the right to return to land
that their families fled in 1948 when
the State of Israel was founded there
are about two million people living here
in the Gaza Strip an areas smaller than
the city of Denver and the majority are
refugees and their descendants the
protests are expected to grow bigger
next week the 70th anniversary of the
founding of the State of Israel when the
US will move its embassy to Jerusalem
that's been condemned by Palestinians
who hope that East Jerusalem will one
day be their capital if they ever get
their own state jury Quran Anthony Holly
Williams in Gaza thank you